Good to see you all today. Uh I'm happy
to have so many clawed lovers in one
room. My name is Alexander Bricken and
I'm on the Applied AI research team here
at Enthropic. And today we're going to
be talking about the thinking lever.
Specifically, we're going to talk about
how Claude leverages compute at runtime,
at inference time, typically called test
time compute to make more effective use
of tokens in solving some of the hardest
problems that Claude has in front of it.
And I'm going to share some of the best
practices when it comes to using
different levers and using different
tokens to essentially try to solve those
problems better. and hopefully you'll
learn something as well.
So looking back a couple years, one of
the key developments in large language
models has been this idea of reasoning
models, which is using test time compute
to spend more tokens for a model to
become more efficient at answering a
question. Similar to how we can scale
model performance at training time, such
as train time compute, test time compute
also results in higher intelligence
results.
So as you can see here on the left we
have our different models in our typical
uh range from haiku sonnet to opus and
as you increase the size of the model or
the number of um parameters you can see
that the performance increases up to
nearly roughly below 80% for an internal
agentic coding benchmark that we run.
Equally on the right hand side here we
have a logarithmic axis on the on the x-
axis and you can see that as claude
spends more tokens we see the actual
performance increase as well and so both
of these the max on the right and the
result that you're seeing here on the
left are actually the same score.
So this is actually true of every
knowledge domain work. So you take a
reasoning problem in darch QA which is a
benchmark computer use through OS world
or humanity's last last exam which is a
PhD level series of test cases. In all
of those results we see that the model
becomes better at producing outcomes
when it uses more tokens to think
through the problem before answering the
questions. as a tangible example. And
even though we love looking at graphs at
Enthropic, I wanted to show uh this in
real time. And so I have this prompt in
front of us here, which is going to be
run at three different levels of effort
for Claude. Low, high, and max. And I'll
show you how the performance increases
as Claude spends more tokens. So this is
our prompt. Creating a realistic
simulation of cars on a one-way street
at a traffic light. Note the one-way
street and the traffic light.
Okay, so our first one, low effort on
Opus 47. It took roughly 50 seconds and
there were roughly 4,600
uh output tokens. And as you can see,
it's actually quite a good simulation.
We have a one-way road. The cars are on
two lanes. Um, they're pulling up to the
traffic light, stopping at a regular
cadence, and then I think we have a few
kind of adjustments we can make in this
simulation to change the spawn rate of
cars or how often it turns red or green.
And so, as you can see, the the cars are
kind of just moving through and then
stop when the the light becomes yellow.
Cool. It's quite simplistic, though.
Now, let's move over to high effort.
Let's turn that effort level up.
Now, you can see on the left, Claude is
actually spending double the amount of
time it takes to run this sim uh to
create this simulation and roughly
double the amount of tokens. And I would
say that this simulation's a little bit
more detailed. We now have same one-way
road, different types of vehicles
showing up. There's a few lorries in
there for the Brits out out in the
crowd. And as well as that, there's a uh
traffic light, but the traffic light
isn't in the middle of the road. Like if
we flip back to the previous example,
you'll see that the traffic light was
positioned in the middle road, which
makes absolutely no sense. whereas now
cla to itself, okay, I should probably
position it sort of overhanging the
road, but it's sort of upside down,
which I don't love. Um, however, I would
say it's a more complex simulation. One
of the things when we ran this prompt as
well that Opus said in this version is,
hey, I've actually worked a little bit
through making the drivers a bit more
intelligent. So depending on how the
cars move, the cars around it also
react, which is a more intelligent
simulation than than the previous
version.
And finally, we ran Claude Opus 47 on
max effort. This is using roughly 10x
the number of tokens and time to run uh
to create this simulation. And as you
can see, it's much more detailed.
Arguably, this is the best traffic light
we've seen. I like that it's sort of up
upside down hanging following the laws
of physics. We also have this beautiful
skyscape in the back. Um, and the cars
also reflect this more intelligent
motion of vehicles.
So, what does this mean? Well, arguably
the more tokens it spends, the more time
it takes. And so over time we might see
Claude eventually go from seconds,
minutes or hours of work to even days,
weeks or months of work. And so this is
the meter benchmark. We're showing that
over generations of models and this is a
combination of both train time compute,
so larger models, as well as better test
time compute, so spending more tokens on
our higher reasoning models. we see that
Claude is able to work more autonomously
to cover human level tasks to a higher
degree of of hours. And so mythos uh
which is one of our latest models works
to an extent of roughly 16 hours of
human work to a 50% uh level of
accuracy. Now test time compute can be
any form of spending tokens.
This is typically at inference time and
there's three ways in which we like to
break this down.
The first way is thinking
space for reasoning. It's basically a
scratch where Claude considers the
question that was asked of it, uses
whatever data it has available to it in
the prompt and thinks about the next
steps it should take to solve a problem.
Equally, there's tool calling right
after. This is Claude's interface with
the outside world. So in this example,
we're asking Claude to do a web search,
learning more about the Anthropic
Developer Conference. Funnily enough,
we're all here right now. And tools can
really be anything though. It's, you
know, 1 million types of tools. Interact
with your Salesforce, call the MCP
server, even write into a file system.
All of those things are tool calls. And
finally, there's text. This is the
output that Claude makes whenever you
ask a question of it, and it responds
with something. It might be a summary of
all the work it did. It might be a
question up front in its in its response
to gather more information from the
user. Test time compute has direct costs
in the form of tokens token count and
time that it takes. And so naturally
your might your mind might be coming to
the conclusion of hey wait a minute as a
user I want more control over what
claude actually does on a data day
basis. So using there's essentially two
ways in which users can change the
number or the amount of test time
compute that cla
to max and depending on the effort you
assign model it will work for a longer
amount of time and spend more tokens. So
often you're kind of asking yourself the
question of okay do I trade intelligence
off for speed.
Secondly we have budgets. Budgets are
basically a way of assigning more strict
constraints to the way cloud works. That
might be through max token constraints
or what we call task budgets which is
another feature in our API. I'm going to
spend the rest of the session
elaborating a little more on effort.
Now the ideal state is you ask cloud a
question and it knows how much effort it
should put into it. Uh but humans always
want to have that additional lever they
can pull to change the effort over a
period of time. And so when we first
released reasoning models, the initial
state was you would ask lot of question
and it would think for a period of time
depending on how many tokens you
allocated to thinking and then it would
execute a series of tool calls reading
each one until the output was formulated
and then you get the response. Now if
you think of the analogy of like how
humans work typically we don't do that.
someone doesn't ask me a question, I
like stand there processing it and then
suddenly I like go execute a bunch of
steps and come back with the answer.
Right? Instead, which is how we resulted
in developing interled thinking,
you do something, you think about it,
you do another thing, you think about
it, and then you come back with a
result. And that's exactly what interle
thinking does. So it allows Claude to
basically have thinking steps after
every tool call it does. Now let's take
it a step further. Adaptive thinking is
basically an evolution of interle
thinking where you give even more
control to the model as to when it
thinks and why it thinks. And so
depending on the question at hand claude
will choose to call either a tool call
output some text like that question I
was referring to earlier or even think
in it in whatever order it likes. And so
looking back to the analogy I was
talking to earlier, that actually
reflects even more of how humans work,
right? Sometimes I might take three
tasks at once and go, you know, if I'm
playing tennis, I go hit the tennis
ball, then run back to the baseline. I'm
not thinking in that instance. If I'm
doing an academic problem set, though, I
am probably thinking at every step of
the process.
Now, Claw can actually choose to not
think at all if it doesn't want to. So
in this example, we could have no
thinking block. Um, and that really just
relates to the question you ask of it,
right? Even with humans, if I asked you,
what is 10 + 10? You'd immediately spawn
respond with 20. Whereas, if I asked
you, you know, work through this really
difficult PhD level problem set, you'd
probably think a lot, but different
members of the audience here might think
for more or less less time. So, it
really depends on the problem, the model
you're using, and how much context you
provided it.
Adaptive thinking isn't a model reader.
We're not classifying the request that
comes through the door. Instead, it's
actually telling Claude, "Hey, you have
this thinking tool.
you must think at one point in time
whereas now clog doesn't have to think
at all if it doesn't need to. We run all
of our benchmarks that you're seeing on
screen on adaptive thinking and we've
found that it's purto efficient relative
to interle thinking the former way in
which we served our models.
So historically users had thought about
thinking as this effort dialer
you can turn on thinking for a better
answer.
That's a reasonable instinct, but in
reality, a thinking toggle is actually a
poor proxy for the amount of effort that
a model should put in.
You're not expressing how hard you want
Claude to think when you turn a thinking
toggle on or off. You're actually just
turning off a core capability. As I
mentioned, there's these three
capabilities: thinking, tool calling,
and text. And so when you turned
extended thinking off, you just remove
that capability from Claude. Now that's
an un ideal outcome, right? Instead, I'd
rather have Claude know that it can
think and work every time using those
thinking tools available to it. So as an
analogy with tool use, we don't tell
Claude to either never search or always
search the web. We just give Claude a
search tool and allow it to reason as to
when it should search.
In a similar way, when we work with our
teammates, I don't tell you, hey, uh,
don't use your inner inner monologue.
Don't think about this problem set. Just
come up with an answer for me. I'll tell
you the constraints of the problem, some
sort of knowledge worker task. You'll go
off and execute on it pending who you
are and what context you have, and then
you'll come back to me with an answer,
and we collaborate as a team member.
Ideally, we want Claude to work in the
same way. So I want to dig a little bit
more into some of the best practices
around using effort
and this graph is an articulation as we
saw before of effort levels increasing
and so so alongside that the
capabilities of models.
So the first thing to think about is you
want to evaluate model performance. So
having a really good test set of the
problem that you're trying to get Claude
to tackle where there's really difficult
challenges that you're proposing to the
model and evaluating at different effort
levels how well the model performs is
one of the best ways to just figure out
what e effort level you should start
with. Now one of the things you might
notice here is there's diminishing
marginal returns to higher effort effort
levels depending on the task. And so we
in in this example we even see that
where max is disproportionately like
double the amount of tokens as extreme
extra high and it's only a marginal bump
in performance. Now loweffort levels I
would say can accomplish a lot of things
but you're often trading off
intelligence for speed. And so sometimes
you might want to think about loweffort
things as things that aren't
intelligencebound.
Things that you can simply accomplish
quickly without the model thinking that
much. As a quick tip, um I'm going to
give an example of loweffort actually
coming up with a really cool way of
working through a problem. You all might
be familiar with Claude plays Pokémon.
It's probably my favorite eval. This
eval is we put Claude into Pokemon Red
and we gave it access to tools to
trigger buttons on like a Game Boy for
example and we gave it vision over the
game and we had it execute and try to
beat the Elite 4, which is the objective
of Pokemon if you're not familiar. And
when we put Claude on low effort, we
actually found that it almost tried to
scapegoat the game. So what it would do
is it would run all sorts of mechanisms
like using repels, using potions to have
to avoid going back to the Pokemon
center, using escape routes to get out
of caves quickly, running away from
poking Pokemon battles whenever
encountered one in the in the shrubs.
And this was really interesting because
when you put it on low effort, Claude
actually came up with this unique
solution to navigate the game and almost
complete it faster than it otherwise
would. So there are some benefits to
doing loweffort because you're
explicitly constraining how much the
model is thinking through the problem
set and maybe it does end up in really
unique attractor states. Now while evals
are always ideal, I understand they're
quite hard. I speak to customers a lot
and often they don't have the perfect
eval. And so I want to give you a quick,
you know, rules of thumbs that you can
use when you think about the different
effort levels that you use. We're going
to start on the right looking at max. As
I mentioned, max effort can typically
deliver gains on the hardest tasks, but
they might show diminishing marginal
returns. And so, I wouldn't recommend
starting here unless you absolutely know
that the intelligence of your use case
is necessary. You know, the problem set
is hard. You know, cloud's going to have
to think a long time.
Extra high is where we've settled as
being the default for cloud code and
cloud.AI.
We would argue that this is one of the
best trade-offs between intelligence,
speed, and number of tokens. As you move
down to high, this is a still a good
balance of token usage and intelligence.
And I would argue that if your use case
requires any intelligence, you should
probably land here. Um, but it will be
faster, of course, than the other two I
just referred to.
Medium and low are ways to just toggle
down that amount of tokens used. And as
a result of that at low as I mentioned
you're really looking at latency
sensitive use cases where maybe it's
classification summarization or data
extraction. Now as I mentioned before we
have these two levers that we think
about enthropic as we develop our
models. One is train time compute and
one is test time compute. So you might
be thinking to yourself, okay, well, how
do I know whether or not I should use a
really small model like Haiku and make
that effort level really high versus
having a really big model and making the
effort level really low? Like what are
the differences there? So I want to give
you a few guidelines for thinking
through that.
On the left you're seeing the Opus
simulation that we created before and on
the right you're seeing this Haiku
simulation uh Haiku 45. And as you can
see Haiku spent roughly half the amount
of time developing the simulation but
the same number of tokens and I would
say the result is not nearly as good. I
don't even know if those are cars to be
honest. Um, and so the conclusion that
we come to here is arguably if the if
the question you're asking of Claude
result needs any intelligence at all,
you're often better off using the larger
model. And specifically, you're better
off using it even if you have the effort
at low.
Now, the way that you should think about
using smaller models though is these low
intelligence use cases where you're not
really caring as much about the outcome
because the outcome is so simplistic
that you know cla
evals to figure out what the best way to
do things is. If you can run haiku,
sonnet and opus on across the range for
all effort levels, that's the perfect
world. Now, obviously, you won't have uh
all of those resources every time. And
so, I'll try to give you some rules of
thumb in a second.
You should enable
Claude that space to reason. give it the
scratch pad so it knows that it can use
that thinking tool when it needs to. You
can control that length through the
effort levels that I described.
Evals are often the best way to find
your ideal balance.
Finding the hardest evaluations are
always the best so that you can know
this is actually representative of the
things that I want Claude to do in the
field.
And then finally, when in doubt, go with
extra high. It's the default that we've
set for our products and I would argue
that it's a great kind of purto
efficient outcome between latency and
number of tokens and intelligence. The
ideal world is that you set the bar in
the budget for the way Claude works. So
let's say I want Claude to work on some
really long horizon task, a day, maybe a
week. I want to be able to say to
Claude, "Hey, I'm only going to spend
this amount on whatever you do." or hey
only take this long a week to do it and
then eventually claude just knows how to
allocate that compute appropriately. So
it knows how many tokens it should spend
and then it goes and executes returning
the result given the constraints you
provided. And so over time what we want
to do is improve the performance of
Claude in recognizing what tasks are
actually important and allowing Claude
to appropriately allocate its resources
to solve them.
Thanks so much for listening. I'm going
to be around the conference if anyone
has any questions and uh hope you enjoy
the rest of the conference.